work hard so super quick video today
guys I don't have a lot of time it's an
insane day trying to get on my book
stuff ready I got all of my books back
from everybody who is reviewing them and
now I have the challenge of reading
through everybody's comments and trying
to pull together notes and purposeful
data and meaningful information and it's
great that all the people that I gave
them to mark them up so much but now I'm
struggling to go through all the notes
and try to figure out what I'm going to
keep and we're gonna cut just so you
have a sense I've taken over the dining
room table here this huge dining room
table with books and then it overflowed
into the living room here what I'm
basically doing is I printed off another
clean copy and I'm going through every
page and I'm rewriting everybody's notes
summarizing underlining what the
underlying putting stars or hearts or
whatever they did on their version and
so now I have one fully crazy mocked up
version but then I can make some
decisions on and see what I need to
change and add and improve and I've gone
through chapter one the shortest chapter
there are ten chapters in the book and
one is the shortest and that's what I've
done so far and it is it is two o'clock
in the afternoon so it's going to be an
insanely long day but it's it's it's
pretty special to see everything come
back and I really feel the love for
everybody who filled the the books out
with comments and notes and so you know
message here for you guys is if you love
what you're doing the time flies you
know like you gotta pour your love into
it this is one of those times where I
just got to put insane I want to love
and energy to pound it through to get
something out for you guys to be able to
enjoy and read so next week I should
hopefully be back on a normal filming
the book video schedule on to your
questions so if you have a question I'm
going to answer about my book about the
book writing process or something
related to working hard leave in the
comments below and I will do my best to
answer in next week's video
it's just past midnight I kind of
finished I'm done for the day I finished
up my Tim Schmoyer hang out at around 12
15 so basically been working nonstop for
12 hours ate lunch while working a
dinner while working had two coffees
went to the bathroom probably five times
from the cuff otherwise have not got up
from looking at the books super grateful
for all the feedback and help it's made
some serious changes to the ballcock I
cut out some major chunks from it that
I'm gonna be putting in his bonus
chapters I'm gonna go to bed with my
wife now because she helped me at the
end thank you baby that's it thanks guys
long rubbed it next week